thanks to audible for keeping legal
eagle in the air
take off the roads please
yeah so it is absolutely true that they
wore judicial robes trying to
get the ire of judge hoffman in response
the judge did
in fact issue contempt citations against
them
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and today we are covering the
trial of the chicago 7 which was written
and directed by aaron sorkin believe it
or not
this is actually a new movie and not
only is it a new movie
but it's a new legal movie it's like the
before times so i'm really excited to
take a look at this movie that involves
one of the most
famous trials in the 1960s and uh yeah
let's get to it
[Music]
december 30th all those whose birthday
falls on december 30. president johnson
announced a new monthly draft totals
increasing to 35 000 43 000 51 000.
yeah it's interesting that in the public
consciousness for some reason
in modern times maybe it's just me but i
think we tend to associate the vietnam
war with richard nixon but for the most
part it was
johnson who really escalated things in
vietnam and
instituted the draft later on i assume
we're going to get to the actual
protests themselves
everyone's protesting johnson and the
democratic nominees because they were
the ones that were largely responsible
for the escalation in vietnam
and that's why everyone got arrested
eventually nixon comes in as this
president that's going to
withdraw from vietnam which he
eventually does in the second term but
for the most part
the democrats were the party that were
pro-vietnam at the time
if america's soul becomes totally
poisoned
part of the autopsy must read vietnam
what we need in the united states is not
hatred it is love
and wisdom so i ask you tonight to
return home
to say a prayer for the family martin
luther king
yeah it's also easy to forget that
martin luther king
and robert kennedy were shot just months
apart from each other and kennedy was
shot right around the time that he won i
think was the day that he won the
california primary
for the democratic nomination and it's
one of the great counterfactuals in the
world
to think about what would have happened
if robert kennedy had won the democratic
nomination if he hadn't been
assassinated before that
when we get to the protest and the trial
itself eventually hubert humphries is
the one that's nominated for the
democratic nomination for president
and he wasn't an anti-war protest and
historians think that if humphreys had
been an anti-war candidate
in 1968 that he would have beaten
richard nixon but
he wasn't and he lost section 2101 of
title 18.
that's the federal law that was broken
that's the rat brown law
conspiracy to cross state lines in order
to incite violence
okay the maximum 10 years we won all 10.
for whom sir the all-star team
okay so this is really interesting and i
think this is kind of a throwaway line
schultz here who is the prosecutor talks
about the h
rap brown law a trap brown was the
chairman of the student non-violent
coordinating
committee in 1967 he gave a speech to
a few dozen people in cambridge maryland
and the quote that he said was something
like it's time for cambridge to explode
we're going to have to burn america down
and then the group of people exchanged
gunfire with the police and it's sort of
an open question who
started that the hrap brown law was
a law that was introduced by strom
thurman who
is notorious for being a sort of racist
senator from the south when the civil
rights act of 1968
was passed or was attempted to be passed
there was obviously quite a lot of
pushback at the time
there was a lot of white fright not only
people protesting the war but also
what people saw as outside agitators
it was a law that was meant to prevent
people from coming out of state
and basically inciting violence often
when you're dealing with federal laws
the way that you overcome the the
commerce clause of the us constitution
and allow congress to actually
legislate something is you say that when
you come out of state or you cross state
lines then that's when the law
applies in order to pass the civil
rights law along with i think it was a
housing bill they had to be passed with
this writer that was added by strom
thurman this was 1969 at the time
no one had ever used this law and it was
clearly passed for political
reasons the fact that bobby seal the
black panther was even included in this
group of
people that actually organized the
protests in 1968
that was politicized the law that they
were prosecuted under was completely
politicized it was
it's as close as america has really ever
come to a political show trial
[Applause]
okay so a couple things here the movie's
telling us this is
district court so it's a federal
courthouse because like i said we're
dealing with a federal law here this was
the hrap brown
anti-rioting act on top of it the chant
that they're chanting here i don't know
if that continued into the trial but
famously
when the police cracked down on the
protesters at the democratic convention
the the protesters themselves as they
were basically being beaten by the
police
were chanting the whole world is
watching the whole world is watching
i assume that that probably continued on
even after the process of stealth but
that that chance famously originated
with the protests
themselves i want you all to meet uh a
new addition to the defense team this is
leonard
wineglass one of this country's most
talented first amendment
can you tell us how to do that go ahead
can you tell us the status of charles
gary
charles gary is still in the hospital
you should
contact his office for information uh
marjorie
does that mean you're representing bobby
seal today oh no it's very important
that he understood that for his
own protection his own protection i will
not be acting as
bobby seal's attorney today all right so
they're hinting at a whole bunch of
different things here number one
is that consular and wineglass were the
main trial counsel for the chicago seven
but
also there were dozens of lawyers that
were involved here it was not just these
two guys
and they're hinting that a man named
charles gary
is not present this is a famous episode
in federal litigation where a lot of the
members of the chicago seven
will release the chicago eight if you
include bobby seal wanted charles gary a
famous litigator to represent them in
particular bobby seal the black panther
wanted charles gary to
represent him and he was in the hospital
because he needed gallbladder surgery so
he was literally in a hospital bed and
so it was a huge
question as to who was representing whom
at the start of the trial i understand
why they're trying to smoke
abby jerry and hayden even running in
dullinger but for the left of me i can't
figure out what the two of us are doing
here
i feel exactly the same way but this is
the academy awards of protests and as
far as i'm concerned it's an honor just
to be nominated
okay this hints that something else is
probably kind of important is that
because this is
kind of a show trial and very
politicized the prosecutors were
cramming a whole bunch of disparate
groups
into the defense table here you had the
yippies that were led by
abby hoffman who thought this was all
kind of a joke you have the sds led by
tom hayden
who were very very anti-war you have
these local guys winer and freunds who
were not
nationally known figures they were just
involved in the local planning but not
really the overarching national campaign
you've got bobby seale who's
the head of the black panthers at this
point and then you have david dellinger
who i think is involved with the mobe
the like student mobilization
against the war and they're all on trial
for a conspiracy to
create a riot winer and and freunds were
completely the odd men out and
it's sort of crazy that all of these
people were prosecuted at the same time
when they couldn't have less to do with
each other really they
barely agreed that everyone should be
against the
the vietnam war but that's kind of where
all the
uh the cooperation ended all rise
hmm okay so if this is actually the
start of the trial itself if we're done
with the pre-trial stuff
then at this point it was already sort
of a circus
and most if not all of the defendants
refused to stand to recognize the judge
which was actually a subject of a lot of
the contempt charges that
judge julius hoffman would hand down to
a bunch of the defendants
especially the yippies with abby hoffman
were absolutely dead set on making this
thing as
wild as much like a circus and showing
the least amount of respect
possible move to reinstate testimony
among the many things that they did they
refused to stand for
large portions of the trial 69 cr
180 united states of america
versus david dillinger bernard c
davis thomas hayden abbott hoffman
jerry c rubin lee winer john
r frowens and bobby g seal for trial
are the people ready to make opening
arguments we are your honor
i don't have my lawyer here it's not
your turn to speak
my trial's begun without my lawyer okay
so
that's bobby seal the the famous black
panther and
they're compressing a lot of stuff into
this statement here because
we haven't even been able to see the the
pre-trial stuff that happened before the
court a lot of stuff that happens in
motion practice
between council and the judge and you're
choosing the jury and
there's so many things that goes into
the pre-trial and here it was a
huge huge issue about who represented
bobby seal by the time that the trial
starts
several of the pre-trial lawyers have
already been held in contempt and
judge hoffman has sent them to jail
without bail which caused over a hundred
lawyers to write an amicus brief where
you're
you're just writing a brief as a friend
of the court you're not someone that
is actually has a vested interest in in
the trial itself but hundreds of lawyers
wrote in to the judge and said this is
crazy
you know why are you jailing the lawyers
for the defendants here and
so it was a complete open question as to
who represented bobby seal william
kunsler the main
trial counsel for the defendants
explicitly said he was not representing
seal
mr seal is here without legal
representation i don't care
for your general tone arguably
seal was completely unrepresented for
most of this trial and
was vociferously disputing the fact that
they were moving forward without someone
representing him i mean this is
part of the whole mess that led to the
circus-like atmosphere of this trial
it's crazy
mr schultz
good morning my name is richard schultz
i'm an assistant u.s attorney for the
southern district of illinois
all right classic trope entering the
well without permission
and going right up to the jury box you
have to ask for permission or obviously
the bailiff will
tackle you there's actually one real
life exchange that was in the transcript
that didn't make it into the movie that
touches on this
so william kunsler is the main defense
lawyer and he was at the lectern but he
was sort of
leaning on the lectern kind of at the
side of the lectern and
judge hoffman basically yelled at him
saying that
mies van der rohn designed the lectern
who's a famous
architect and he's not allowed to even
lean on it it's disrespectful
really in this movie we see the tip of
the iceberg
in terms of the judge's animosity
towards not only the defense council
but also the idea that he was somehow
racist
for chastising bobby seal and
that he was constantly the butt of the
joke any time there was laughter he
basically issued a contempt citation to
the defense counsel and
he was always worried that people were
laughing at him and he was always
worried that people thought he was
racist
and he went out of his way in sort of a
racist way to
say that he wasn't racist and he would
kept saying you know i've got
black friends it was just really really
obvious stuff
where he was trying to make a point to
show that he wasn't racist and yet
demonstrating that
he was at least mildly racist for the
time
mr schultz
radical left that's all the radical left
in different costumes
that's probably improper for an opening
statement these defendants had a plan
and a plan among two or more people is a
conspiracy
the defendants cross state lines to
execute their plan that's why we're in
federal court and the plan was
to incite a riot and there's one thing
you already know
they succeeded yeah so there was a riot
there's no doubt about that but
several investigations showed that it
was the police that started the riot
there was a congressional or illinois
state
investigative report called the waka
report that basically concluded that it
was the police not the protesters who
started the riot in 1968 and it's
interesting because here there are two
separate types of charges for the most
part
one is a conspiracy charge to cross
state lines to
create a riot the other charges were
just sort of general
incitement to riot charges that
regardless of whether there was a plan
or conspiracy that they did
cause a riot to happen and the reason
that you can
charge all these people together and try
them together is the conspiracy
charge because generally defendants have
a right to their own trial but
when the government alleges a conspiracy
then you can lump them all together and
it's much easier to use
statements to show a plan amongst this
group of people which
didn't really exist they are a really
disparate group of people that
yes got together for this protest or
what they call the love in
but it's very unlikely that there was
any kind of thought out plan to actually
incite a riot ahead of time your honor
i'm not with these guys i never even met
most of them until the indictment
we will have ordered the eight of us
here and they are silent
free to chicago seven i'm not with them
mr marshall you're saying it's a
conspiracy
indictment and speaking frankly the u.s
attorney wanted a negro defendant to
scare the jury i was thrown in
to make the group look scarier i came to
chicago i made a speech mr seal
chicken pot pie went to the airport and
i flew back to oakland and that's why
they call it the chicago get your hands
off me
charge mr seal with one count of
contempt of court
so contempt of court it was a huge issue
in this trial by the end of the trial
there were 175 different
counts of contempt and between four of
the defendants and two of the lawyers
some people were sentenced to more than
four years in jail as a result of the
contempt violation that the judge handed
down
i mean it's crazy that that people would
be sentenced to four years in jail for
contempt of court for things that
happened in court
not even the things that they were
alleged to have done outside of court
again it contributed to this idea that
this was a political show trial
rumors were that the prosecutors really
really wanted to get
judge hoffman and they were ecstatic
when they did get him because he was
just bringing down the hammer
on all of these different defendants so
the question is
what do you do if you're the defense
counsel and the judge
hates you and is really taking it out on
you and your client
really william kunsler probably should
be the star of this show because
this movie is only the tip of the
iceberg in terms of
how much the judge really hated kunzler
and the rest of the defendants
counselor was fighting back for months
and months and as a result
he was issued dozens of contempt
citations along with the defendants
themselves the only thing you can do is
just set your record you know
that a lot of these rulings are not
going to stand that you're going to be
able to appeal it and
if the judge is poisoning the well then
you just keep setting the record you
make your objections you state your
grounds for the
the objection so that when the trial is
over and if there is a conviction
you can go to the court of appeals and
point to these things frankly
this this movie doesn't show just
how far counselor was willing to go to
fight this judge who absolutely hated
him and his clients
what are you wearing it's an homage to
you
your honor do you have clothes
underneath here yes
hold on yes take off the robes please
yeah so this was one of the many antics
that abby hoffman
and jerry rubin pulled during the course
of this trial it is absolutely true that
they wore judicial robes
trying to get the ire of judge hoffman
they were not wearing police uniforms
underneath
but in response to wearing those robes
the judge did
in fact issue contempt citations against
them did you issue the permits
no i did not and what if anything did
abby hoffman say when you denied the
request for the permits
mr style you need to understand
something there's going to be a festival
of life in grand park
and it will be held during the
convention bands will play rock music
there will be public fornication likely
some of it with the wives and mistresses
of delegates
psychedelic long-haired leftists will
consort with dope users
and we're going to insist that the next
president in the united states stop
sending our friends to be slaughtered
these things are going to happen whether
you give us the permit or not
the hotels will be filled with delegates
where will people sleep some people who
sleep in tents others will live
frivolously
how many people are coming here a lot
what's a lot thousand
two thousand ten thousand jesus christ
right so the the permit issue was
a really big deal because this is a
really weird
trial in terms of the evidence that was
presented and allowed to be presented
you're trying to show that there's this
conspiracy ahead of time to cause a
right to
incite violence so a lot of what
these defendants said and did goes to
whether there was a plan
to create violence or rioting before it
actually happened and you can imagine
that
permitting is a big issue here there's a
lot of people a lot of historians that
think that if the permits had been
granted
they would have had things like
sanitation and electricity and
the bands that they had lined up to play
would have had a pa system
which could have calmed the crowd down
and of course the permits were rejected
he said we must understand that as we go
forth to try to move the reprobate
politicians your honor
our cowardly congress the jive
double lip talker nixon doublelift
talking nixon
you make me sound like one funky cat
thank you sir
last warning mr seal did he say anything
else
he said the revolution at this time is
directly connected to organized guns
in force no more questions
job double lip talking funky [ __ ] again
would the defense like to cross-examine
the witness yes
i'm sitting here saying that i would
like to cross-examine the witness only
lawyers can address
my lawyer is charles gary i'm tired of
hearing that couldn't care less what
you're tired of
what did you say
i said it would be impossible for me to
care any less
what you are tired of and i demand to
cross-examine
the witness sit in your chair and be
quiet
and don't ever address this court in
that manner again
so this incident actually happened this
is one of the more infamous
uh incidents in uh litigation uh history
around this time it actually happened
earlier uh it was not related to the
death of fred hampton but
obviously bobby seale wanted a lawyer
and
the court wasn't allowing him to have
his counsel of choice
after a number of disruptions judge
hoffman really did put bobby seal
in chains bound and gagged and what's
not portrayed in this movie is that it
wasn't an isolated incident but he
stayed in chains for days
you can imagine that the other
defendants were pissed the juries
sort of tainted at this point this could
have been its own movie
it sort of gets short shrift in in this
particular movie but
it actually happened and it's not the
shining moment for the judicial system
state your name william ramsay clark
do you swear the testimony you give will
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
i do you would think that this was pure
movie magic it's made up that
they were able to call the former
attorney general for the united states
to be a witness in the trial it actually
happened interestingly what this movie
portrays that the questions are asked he
gives great answers for the defense
about the political nature of this trial
and the judge
does exclude the testimony the jury
never got to hear the testimony of
ramsay clarke this is interesting
because
generally you would think that what
another police department did or in this
case the attorney general's office did
isn't really probative or relevant to
the idea that these people are guilty or
not but there is a defense of
being singled out for political reasons
and i assume that that would have been
an affirmative defense in this
particular case
what actually happens is that while
ramsay clerk did not get to testify in
this trial
eventually after the appeal and a
retrial he
was able to testify later on he
testified but
the jury never got to hear it it's
interesting what they're not showing
here because there were
hundreds of witnesses and because the
defendant's states of mind were at
issue they called a whole bunch of
people who participated
in the protest witnesses like alan
ginsberg the poet dick gregory the
comedian
folk singers timothy leary the harvard
professor who
was famous for experimenting with lsd
the testimony that they gave was insane
people
sang songs they chanted in the middle of
the courtroom
and this was the testimony in front of
the judge and jury this was
a bonkers trial from start to finish
[Music]
all right now it's time to give the
trial of the chicago 7 a grade for legal
realism
on the one hand a lot of the dialogue
that's in this movie is
almost verbatim from the trial
transcripts of things that actually
happened and
sure they're condensing things to fit it
into a two-hour movie but it seems like
they got a lot of the period details
correct
on the other hand there are a few movie
tropes moving around the well but for
the most part this is a pretty accurate
movie both from the legal perspective
and the historical perspective as well
so i'll give the trial of the chicago
seven an a minus for accuracy this is
about as accurate as you'll get for a
two hour movie
condensing six months worth of trial to
prepare for this review i read tons of
books and court pleadings but
one of my favorite things was listening
to amazing voice actors read
the most exciting excerpts from the
trial transcript on audible in the trial
of the chicago 7
the official transcript the amazing cast
includes jeff daniels luke kirby and
jk simmons who plays judge hoffman and
is completely terrifying i got federal
court ptsd
just from listening to him and while the
movie is good the reenactment on audible
is even better because
truth is stranger than fiction the movie
just couldn't do justice just to how
many crazy things actually happened in
the trial
and how heated the arguments were
between consular and judge hoffman trust
me the audiobook is fantastic it's
better than a john grisham novel i use
audible almost every day it's by far the
best source of audio entertainment and
they recently launched a new plan called
audible plus that gives you full access
to their plus catalog
which is filled with thousands and
thousands of select originals audiobooks
podcast workouts and even guided
meditations and now is the best time to
try audible plus because with their
holiday offer
it's only 4.95 a month for the first six
months and after that it's only 7.95 a
month to download and stream their
thousands of audio books and originals
in the plus catalog and with audio plus
you can download or stream without limit
just go to audible.com
legaleagle or text legal eagle to
500-500 and be sure to check out the
audiobook version of the real-life trial
of the chicago 7.
again just go to audible.com legaleagle
to get the holiday offer on audible plus
plus clicking on the link in the
description really helps out this
channel
so do you agree with my analysis leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my real lawyer reactions
including
legally blonde and liar liar so just
click on this playlist and i'll see you
in court